florida republicans have officially
voted to strip disney of their special
governing status
and we saw today their stock dip by a
little bit but it's not about that
little bit it's about getting woke and
going broke in the in the early uh in
the first quarter of this year they're
down i think 15 netflix is down 37
and i do attribute that to wokeness now
of course the media is trying to say
they're losing subscribers that's why
it's happening and it's all because of
competition yeah but they've also lost
conservatives libertarians anti-woke
people and that adds up so they're down
i think 200 000 subscribers they're
blaming password sharing but i have to
be honest the people who are password
sharing probably wouldn't buy netflix
they just be like
some might i bet a lot won't we'll see
if they can recover from this but uh we
have a lot to go through as well because
um we have this we have jen sackey who
is now crying on on a podcast about
florida's parental rights and education
bill and then while that's happening
interestingly mcdonald's has a former i
think it's the former a former ceo who
is trying to purge wokeness from the
company tesla of course is doing better
than ever their sales are skyrocketing
and elon musk wants to buy twitter all
of that good crazy stuff so we'll get
into that plus we'll probably talk a
little bit about that doxxing story with
taylor lorenz and dive into those
stories joining us today to talk about
all of this stuff is tom fitton
thanks for having me guys yeah lady
thank you
uh introduce yourself i'm tom fitton i'm
president of judicial watch which is the
number one government watchdog group in
the country if not the world given the
impact we have on
figuring out what the corrupt
politicians here or there in washington
dc and elsewhere up to and we'll
confront them wherever we can and expose
what's happening
right on we've got james yeah we're
excited to have you back it was a great
conversation last time and
i'm seamus coughlin i am a cartoonist i
am the creator of freedom tunes if you
guys want to go check that out we
released a video yesterday on the
democratic party's wonderful strategy of
promoting grooming um and or opposing it
to grooming laws and we're going to be
releasing a cartoon tomorrow about the
the requirement for masks being removed
by the government i don't want to spoil
your uh
your show but i want to tell people what
you were just doing i really want to oh
my gosh all right i had to record some
audio perhaps we tell them tomorrow
after it's released like i got the
inside scoop on what just happened
because it was funny all right crazy
because i don't want to i don't want to
spoil the joke so tomorrow we give a
little sneak peek a little audio sneak
peek what i'm talking about happy 420
everybody i just looked up what's 420
code term that refers to the consumption
of cannabis i still don't know exactly
why or where but i'm going to look into
it
uh great to see you and maybe we can
talk about later in the show corruption
and the value of corruption because i
think in a system that's too ordered
there's no room for growth
especially an authoritarianly ordered
system you need what they would consider
corruption to break out of it
but we'll go into that later oh man
that's that it depends on the definition
of corruption
yeah yeah we will have to get into that
for sure thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen for tuning in this evening i
was gonna say 420 sounds like a police
code which would be interesting if
people are being arrested for smoking
marijuana hopefully that's what isn't
that 3 11 or chicago it's possible i
don't know yeah i don't know i don't
know anyway my friends before we get
started we have an amazing sponsor it is
biotrusts keto elevate c8mct oil powder
head over to eatriteanfeelwell.com
and you can get your supply of keto
elevate for up to 51 off today this is
it's it's medium chain triglycerides
basically you mix it in with your drinks
or your coffee it's kind of creamy and
it gives you that great energy if you're
trying to cut out sugars which i've
completely done you know i've been doing
i've been mixing egg with walnut flour
and then using that to make a bun for
like an egg sandwich it's delicious i
like walnut flour better than almond
flour but i love mixing this stuff into
my coffee head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll get a 60
day money back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite management mental clarity and
focus athletic performance
five grams of the highly sought after
mct eight per scoop
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order and i
trust
that the core fans of timcast irl have
memorized that spiel by now
but uh thank you very much biotrust you
know we don't we don't have that issue
that some of these other podcasters have
where they get cancelled and they lose
all of their sponsors but uh i can only
say you reap what you sow gentlemen also
biotrust is amazing that mct oil is
incredible it makes you feel good it's a
little sweet it's so good for you it's
it's not really sweet yeah it's like if
you haven't had a lot of sugar in your
diet you can taste this
coconutty it's incredible head over to
timcast.com and support our journalists
we've we've got people working every day
breaking news stories you know reaching
out to sources to get you accurate
information as a member at timcast.com
you're helping that keep going and
that's the mission we're also working on
building culture like we've got a kids
show that's going to be based on chicken
city family content because we want to
bring people towards our sphere of
influence which is to convince them
about personal responsibility liberty
all of that good stuff that's our
mission you support it as a member and
you'll get access to exclusive episodes
of this podcast monday through thursday
at 11 p.m they're usually around a half
an hour long and we would appreciate
your support but don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
wherever you can that's also powerful
and let's read this first story from
timcast.com
breaking
florida senate passes legislation ending
disney's tax privilege self-governing
power and special exemption status so
ron desantis the governor of florida is
like they could have they can just build
a nuclear power plant on their own like
they're able to do certain things that
nobody else is able to do so i think
they're right to be looking at this and
reevaluating it i want to say the most
important element of this story is that
disney decided to get woke they thought
they could push the the push all of us
around and say you know what the
activists employees are complaining
about wokeness let's just give them what
they want well now they are seeing that
you reap what you sow you want to come
out and you and you think that you can
just adopt ideology
say you will be political disney was
outright like we're going to defeat this
bill florida said okay you want to get
political we'll take away your special
status now we're seeing as of today
their stock has dropped by 5.56 percent
on top of that their stock was already
hurting this year it's good to see real
economic consequences right freedom of
speech doesn't mean freedom from
consequences right disney i want to see
more companies who want to act a fool
and play dirty games
see actual
accountability my thoughts were
yes you break up that big corporate
you know monopoly break it up that's why
we have anti-trust laws that's why we
have a government in places to protect
us from these insidious things like
corporate people whatever but tom when
you came in here you made a great point
that how far is this going to go how
much authority should a government have
to stop the private sector
well you know look disney
is uh the leadership of disney is
abusing shareholder dollars by uh
spending them improperly
to target or promote
talking
about sexual activities with young
school children
and uh if you're a shareholder you're
you ought to be saying why aren't you
producing more and better product
and increasing shareholder value should
go ahead just real quick i mean on that
point should the shareholders sue for a
violation of their of the company's
fiduciary duty
well i ain't no lawyer but uh
the people have been sued for less
that's for sure in terms of stock with
stock fights and things like that and
shareholder lawsuits
but secondly though you've got this
special
position that disney has in florida it's
been around since 1967 and they're
talking about taking away some
governance that benefits disney
corporate wise and arguably the state
and so the concern i have is is this
being considered
for
uh reasons that are
neutrally applied meaning it's a bad
idea to provide corporations these
special
tax incentives and such
or is it a political payback and if it's
the second one
the danger is
that look the left almost always
controls the leverage of power so if the
new standard is that if corporations
break free and you know start engaged in
politics the way disney has either on
the left or the right is it going to be
a free-for-all in terms of punishing
corporations through government action
let's say in california they go after a
defense contractor or in new york they
go after a gun manufacturer uh and uh
well in fact that's actually what's
happening yeah they're all right they're
already talking about doing that without
any of this being right it's already
happening right and it's and it's been
consistently
people who oppose the cult wokeness
fringe
ideology who have been getting attacked
what's happening like this like the
first time republicans are like okay you
know what we're not going to tolerate
you getting into this and and to be
clear i'm not saying i oppose what
florida did i'm just highlighting
well let's let's be aware of uh what's
happening out there in the culture and
that corporations when they engage in
politics
there's going to be payback uh now and
again and you know florida is making a
policy decision they got this major
corporation that's decided to take the
benefits they're getting from the public
and target school children
and so that's the reaction you're going
to get from the elected representatives
of the public well you're not going to
use to say these special benefits
anymore
uh on behalf of an agenda that we didn't
sign up for when we gave them to you to
begin with i don't i don't think it's as
bad as as you as you might be making it
seem whether it's intention or not this
is disney who has no business in
education policy
deciding to come out because a fringe
faction of activists at their company
complained they ignore the the activists
at the company who are like we don't
want to be involved in this
if a gun company in new york said we're
going to lobby for gun rights that makes
sense
if disney said we are going to lobby for
entertainment rights and special
privileges i'd be like okay well that
makes sense
if a gun manufacturer gun manufacturer
came out and said we're going to start
dumping money into getting religion put
in schools i'd be like they shouldn't be
doing that if they started saying you
know if they said our mission is to
defeat they said like you're a gun
company what are you doing disney's
doing that doing exactly that they have
no business they're doing it for pr
reasons well if they want to be involved
in politics as a political organization
they got to play by the rules and this
is what happened i'll tell you what man
disney has been attempting to educate
kids since the inception of the company
they make cartoons for little kids and
they put subliminal ideas like the
developer you see all sorts of crazy
occult stuff in it um if you really look
for and there's tons of youtube videos
about it conspiracy or whatever but
that's the basic indoctrination of
children is cartoons on tv and that's
disney's specialty so i'm not really
even i mean walt was a great man but
when he died so in my opinion so did
that company man it's no longer they
should have to change the name or
something that's abusive we'll read
through some of these super chats but
someone did mention just now the
buildings probably aren't up to code
so if if disney it's disney world i
think right whatever yeah in florida if
they're under a special governing status
i'm willing to bet they do not conform
to florida building code which means now
that they lose this status yo they're
going to get shut down i mean what
they're this
hey you want to bring disney to heel
this is how you do it and when you see
into ian's point uh i think it was
christopher ruffo who disclosed these
zoom meetings with disney producers and
executives and creators
talking about pushing their agenda this
radical sexual identity agenda
in the cartoons and in the content
targeting your children
so
for all the caution let's be clear here
disney is engaged by their own admission
in pushing propaganda on young children
that parents would reject and taxpayers
want no part of in florida that's what's
clear this wouldn't be happening if the
politicians didn't think
our voters don't you know want this
and certainly disney has their ability
every right and they've got all the
money in the world to persuade uh the
voters otherwise to keep their special
benefits but
it's a hard argument to make
yeah um so disney is not a company that
i happen to be a fan of ian i i agree
with a lot of what you said and i agree
with what you're saying now they
essentially want to use their platform
to to push and normalize perverse sexual
lifestyle choices onto children on top
of that they have sex abuse scandals we
know that they have hired people who
were convicted of child sex abuse in the
past on the disney channel specifically
so not a good company
yes icarly was that what it was i'm not
so oh there's talk about that
there's talk about that but i'm
referring specifically to brian peck
um who was
uh convicted
and then later after he served uh hired
by disney to consult over the phone
because he wasn't allowed to actually be
in the presence of children and then
there was also there's this if you just
look at these memes every few months
they arrest child traffickers at disney
well i mean
of course these people are going to want
to work there right they want to get
access to kids and disney apparently
doesn't do enough screening to stop them
or they're not paying attention to the
trafficking that's occurring under their
noses i mean you know we're all
concerned about critical race theory in
the schools but at least there's like
political accountability there in theory
so everything you're concerned about in
the schools is already happening on the
disney channel
uh nickelodeon and it's all targeted
very young children
the far left is taking control of
children's programming and it isn't just
uh reading writing and arithmetic
teaching kids how to read it's
social cultural transformation
on television
and disney's now being kind of forced to
admit it
uh because you know they're they're in
the business of teaching their kids
teaching your kids
values that are very different than the
parents expect from the content and if i
well i am a parent but we don't we don't
watch those visiting shows anymore but i
would not allow any of this children's
program to be seen by my children until
i had seen it first don't give your kids
cell phones yeah home school kids so i
i'll only i defer to the big tech ceos
these these these executives who don't
give their kids cell phones
why is it that the people who work at
you know big social media companies are
like i am like i'm not gonna let my kid
have a phone cause they know what's on
these websites have you noticed like
this weird psycho social psychosis of
the last decade has really coincided
with the proliferation of these devices
too absolutely mm-hmm
it's simple when someone's in a cult
to get them out of the cult you have to
separate them from cult members and
deprogram them but with the existing
woke cult it's right there in the palm
of their hands
every every time someone says something
you know hey this isn't true you need to
get away from this they retreat back to
their fantasy world and the most
vulnerable is the children that's the
reason i'll tell you i'll tell you right
now what's what's one of the most
infuriating things because i i can't
stand the media lying is the taylor
lorenz story where washington post and
i'll show a clarification for things i
was saying yesterday and things i said
today because i want to make sure i get
all the facts correct in the original
washington post article that doxxed the
creator of libs of tiktok they linked to
a real estate license which included a
private home address
it was a commercial residential mixed
property listed as a business address
but also according to public records a
private residential address for the
creator of the libs of tick tock and
they also explained they didn't link to
they explained how to get their their
private phone number so
they said you know the phone record is
found here associated with this domain
which took me
two seconds to just google and then
three seconds to do a dns so i'm not but
but i want to be careful with my
language they didn't link to the number
they just told you
gave you the instructions the name you
need to look for with the thing to find
it and so uh this one's really
frustrating because i'm seeing many
prominent left-wing personalities just
go they never linked to any private
details i'm seeing the washington post
say we never link to private details and
i'm like yo these people are in a cult
well some of them are saying they never
linked to private details and some of
them are saying that it's good that they
link to private details i'm seeing both
takes well now the the the door's been
opened on that one and you know this guy
responded to me and he's like tim your
followers have been doing this for years
and i'm like i don't think you watch my
show i don't think you know who our
followers are like we we don't we don't
have that kind of audience you can't
control your followers you can only give
them advice and guidance but it's
everyone has to make their own choice we
don't have followers who do that stuff
like i mean i'm sure there's a couple
people here and there watch the show but
we are not on these platforms where
we're engaging in overt activism in fact
you know i told the guy
i think doxxing the name of libs of
tic-tac was wrong and he's like you mean
to tell me that if you got the name of
some antifa account you wouldn't publish
the name and i was like yes i would not
how many times have you guys heard me
say i won't say their name yeah i say it
all the time minimize harm
i even sometimes refuse to say jenk
yuger's name when the story is about the
youngsters because i'm trying to avoid
drama and trying to talk about concepts
and philosophy these people
they don't
i feel like their goal is specifically
to keep people in the dark for political
power they are evil when the washington
post came out and said we never did that
and you can pull up the archive and just
see that they did i'm like these people
are downright evil so are they lying
they they put a link to this address is
that different than posts
no they said we did not link to it
outright i will assert as a statement of
fact the washington post
linked to the private home address of
the creator of libs of tick tock it's as
if they didn't think they were doing it
so then they said they didn't but they
did
well and then just lying because they're
evil people yeah and even if they didn't
know that's almost worse and then they
deleted it so obviously they knew yep
they edited the page good point you know
i i think a lot of these media become uh
you know they sometimes engage in
journalism but places like the
washington post have just become
left-wing advocacy groups that sometimes
create journalism that's valuable but
you know judicial watch you know we're a
non-profit we do lots of
talking about policy we educate people
we do journalism
but you know i would be hard to argue
that we weren't advocating for certain
values and the washington post is
more activists than any political group
group i know
in the movements of both the left or the
right in terms of pushing forward
narratives and agendas and in the case
of lawrence
or or outing the uh author of the libsar
tick tock
tweet feed
it wasn't
it's problematic obviously that they uh
exposed her but more importantly they
lied about the content
and it wasn't it was exposing her to
attack and belittle the content
and cut off
access to it from the public or is a
judicial watch a 501c3 or c4 so we're a
501c3 which to those who don't follow
the irs code means we're a charity
meaning you we can take tax deductible
contributions it also means you can't
engage in overtly political activity uh
it generally means that we can't uh
endorse or oppose candidates yeah and
you know i can talk about politics but i
can't uh you know say vote for
republicans or democrats can you say who
you're going to vote for
i could in my personal capacity uh but i
choose not to generally because of the
nature of our work because we end up
suing everyone i want to give taylor the
benefit of the doubt really quick
because it's possible that when she
wrote this article she thought she was
linking to the business address and then
it went up and then they were like we
didn't we didn't we do it and then when
they realized they did they pulled it
down she's still denying it and so we're
now we're awaiting them to be like
actually we accidentally we did no that
is the benefit of the doubt at least ian
you can't she did she outright denied it
to me but it doesn't matter what she
said they did it i know they did yes she
outright denied it to me personally i
did not publish the home address then
the washington post said we didn't link
to private information they are just
lying on top of lies because they are
not good people don't give them the
benefit of that when they're lying ex
like overtly and i'm just i'm
flabbergasted by the it's like imagine
being is that family guy joke imagine
being in an elevator with one other
person who just lets out a big fart
looked at you and says you did it guess
what i'm like what yeah i was like dude
i watched you do it what are you lying
only the benefit of the doubt in that i
want to understand why it happened and
never a tribute to malice what could
have been attributed to stupidity it's a
thing i've heard in the past so maybe
yeah i mean they're not you know my my
view on the post now is if a post
reporter called me up to find out where
a court hearing is say oh yeah what's
here what's the case about it's about
this
but if they're calling me up to talk
about conservatives and
what's our view on topic a and b
i say i'm not talking to you i mean
you're you're left-wing just honest
advocates and i'm not going to waste my
breath talking and explaining our views
to you
so you can attack whoever it is you're
trying to attack
usually people who are aligned with our
values they're playing their game i want
to make sure everybody understands this
there is no way you can talk to a
journalist you are not smarter than them
they have a plan they know what they're
doing you will not go on the daily show
you will not go on jim jeffries you will
not go on john oliver you think you're
smart you think if i explain my
positions i'll tell you some of the
tricks they do first of all when it
comes to these comedy news shows they'll
just manipulate what you said because
they're allowed to do it because it's a
comedy show but let's say
you tell a journalist something
explicitly like i reject and refuse
the uh i completely reject racism it is
completely wrong and i up i oppose these
racist organizations instead of quoting
you if they want to get a narrative they
will say when asked about their racist
ties they became belligerent huh
right and you'll be alive but i told
them they don't have to put that in
there they can just say they became
outraged and belligerent
i i believe it was because they were
truly racist and they won't tell the
world what you said i had a guy hit me
up from the daily beast and i gave him
quotes he cut out any quote that made me
look good and then here's another trick
they do you think you can give them a
good quote just one solid quote they
might still use it with ellipses you'll
say something like
that man who came out and said pizza is
disgusting that man was wrong and
they'll put dot quote dot dot pizza
disgusting dot dot dot quote and they'll
say he he literally said those words and
when you were like i was quoting someone
else like did you you can't sue him over
it it's not it's a statement of fact
that said you said it and you can be
like yeah but but i wasn't referring to
that way but you did it yeah it's it's
the story i want to mention about this
reporter from the boston globe who wrote
that based stick man this is back during
the battle of berkeley several years ago
was a white nationalist and i messaged
him and i was like i saw you wrote that
and like this guy's got a got a
his wife's like you know asian mixed
race he's got a mixed race kid it's like
i think you're wrong and he goes is the
guy white i said yes is he a nationalist
yes he's a white nationalist and i was
like wow dude you can't follow you
cannot talk to these people right and so
we see this all the time happen
jordan clepper i think his name is he
shows up to these rallies and these
people think they can talk to him and
then what he does is he cuts it all up
and makes him look insane and then he
puts it on tv and who's he with
uh it's comedy central i don't know if
he's still doing it maybe he's on the
daily show now whatever yeah but they
all do it another problem with these
like live
shows with live audiences is unless the
host is willing to tell the audience to
shut up when they start booing and
heckling the audience will shout you
down when you're making a good point and
then the host will be like if they have
an agenda so you need like an ethical
host to like keep everything ordered not
jon stewart that dude's ratings are in
the gutter yeah i mean i used to do
politically incorrect back in the day
back when mar was on abc and you know
i'd be the lone conservative typically
and getting booed all the time for the
entire half hour and uh you know it's
not fun
but you know at least you get to say
your piece because it's it's hard to
edit what you're saying right those are
better but but uh i agree with you uh
you know generally talking to the media
is a bad idea i used to talk to
reporters at the daily beast and i
stopped talking to them because i give
them a quote and the headline would be
conservatives get hysterical about ex
i'm not i'm not playing i'm not giving
you material to attack
america with i'm not doing it anymore
and it's kind of a it's tricky for
because you know judicial watch our goal
is to educate people so i want the word
about everywhere
but you know when it comes to the media
it's been so corrupted
uh
we can't play their game anymore and and
even even uh there are many prominent
youtube personalities independent uh
personalities who are progressive or
liberal and it's remarkable how either
they are completely incompetent or are
just outright lying and i i'm i'm
confused by this but i won't give any i
don't give these people the benefit
benefit of the doubt anymore because i
there there's there's a few people that
i've actually dm'd with and i'm like
here's the public record
here's the link to the story here's a
screen grab showing where you can click
it to get the address
we don't need to argue whether it was
libs of tick tock's private home address
regardless it was a private contact
address for the individual
no it wasn't
and i'm like
you know what there's no point talking
to tribalists no i think making your own
youtube videos or internet videos is
really the way to go it's they can
attempt to take it out of context and
they can unethically sometimes kind of
but you get your point across that way
let's talk about uh we got this story
from the new york post jen seki breaks
down while discussing harsh and cruel
cruel lgbtq legislation wow sounds mean
sounds like there's some mean laws here
we go white house press secretary jen
seki began sobbing during an interview
this week as she talked about a spate of
bills that critics say are targeting gay
and transgender children claiming that
kids are being used as weapons in a
political culture war zaki was asked
during the interview with news not noise
podcast about legislation like florida's
so-called don't say gay bill which
prohibits the discussion of sexual
orientation or gender identity in
kindergarten through third grade as well
as instruction on those topics and in a
place in manner that's not
age-appropriate
quote this is a political wedge issue
and an attempt to win a culture war seki
said as she began audibly weeping
and they're doing that in a way that is
harsh and cruel to a community of kids
i'm going to get emotional about this
issue because it's horrible but it's
like kids who are bullied and all these
leaders are taking steps to hurt them
and hurt their lives and hurt their
families and you look at some of these
laws in these states and it's going
after parents who are in loving
relationships who have kids it's
completely outrageous sorry this is an
issue that makes me completely crazy
gensaki is a sociopath i don't want
completely crazy people in government
she admitted it not going to get so
first of all the new york post should
not be calling it lgbtq legislation
new york post mark moore
you should correct this because
the parental rights in education has
more to do with parents having access to
information about the schools and gender
identity and orientation is also about
being straight it's just
orientation which could be straight or
not in which case it is just legislation
on sex ed and it's not even that it's
the parental rights and education bill
so get that right gensaki knows this
they look
we are well past the point where i'm
going to assume genseki doesn't know
what about what this bill is she's
crying crocodile tears to manipulate
people because liberals are people who
according jonathan heights research
are more interested in care and fairness
more emotional aspects as opposed to
sanctity purity authority loyalty etc
liberty
so when you approach a conservative and
they have six moral foundations there is
authority authority and loyalty there is
sanctity purity things like that and you
say
dryly and as a matter of factly they're
going to say okay
the left needs to win by making you cry
by crying and begging for care begging
for sympathy so when jen starts crying
she wants people to go oh jenna yo it's
so it's so oh well it's so embarrassing
i mean i remember after but it works
freaking out
one thing that i saw after the 2016
election that really struck me was the
fact that they were posting pictures of
themselves crying and i thought how can
you have such little dignity that you
think that's a good look i i i would be
mortified first if i cried over an
election and i was sitting there bawling
my eyes out you can believe i wouldn't
be posting pictures of it on the
internet the next day as if that was a
good look for me as we're talking about
it i'm thinking hitler's girlfriend
probably cried when he killed himself
like yeah crying emotional doesn't mean
you're right people get emotional about
evil if they're on the side of evil yeah
this girl totally lost it yeah i've
watched murderers cry and you in videos
like they're in a criminal trial and
they're crying i i think sachi's
outsized role in the white house is
something worth discussing beyond the
points that you're making about her
misleading and false statements
uh
it's almost as if she's presidential
you know they issued a statement uh from
jen sackey on
i don't know something had passed just
last week or something that they
objected to and it was a statement as if
the president had issued it it was
statement by white house secretary press
secretary jen sackey and i remember
thinking well this is odd it sounds
presidential
and uh to me her outsized role in this
administration
is further indication
of the diminished
uh cognitive abilities of the president
of the united states it's clear come on
man she is running yeah come on boy she
is running the show and certain and
certainly uh
beyond uh any normal press secretary
donald trump was except for joseph
terribles
donald trump was funny and he talked in
a funny way one of the one you know what
i absolutely love about trump is this
bit where he will say something
outrageous and then when the press
challenges him he'll be like well that's
what i was told like like that like if
that absolves him of being wrong so it's
like
i laugh at that
i'm critical of it donald trump will be
like you know we've got this new
medication coming out and they're like
sir you know a question for mr president
that that is not correct you're talking
about an old report that's since been
debunked i was told this just a moment
ago that's what i was told and it's it's
funny because that's like his defense
joe biden
is different like that's donald trump's
like cognitive faculties trying to
muster up something you know he can't
just come out and be like okay well i
was wrong about that because he's
because he's trump but at least he said
something we understand right well they
told me that that's why i'm saying it
joe biden
he says america can be described in in
in one word
i'm a from from an inheritance
and i was like
what what word was that
tim and then you've got you've got next
no resident batacaf care shouldn't have
shop at a pressure
dude it's not even speaking words i
think you missed this point you saying
this country is indescribable it's that
feeling
it gives him it's just the emotions
it's so overwhelming he can't speak you
know be funny like on the teleprompter
it actually said that and it's like when
everybody makes fun of me get sad
because he thought he made up a great
new word because
well does that not sound like a snopes
like dude webster is going to start
adding this stuff to the dictionary like
a rock musician from the early 90s you
know on a sidebar judicial watch issue
we had caught uh saki lying about
biden's dog bites uh you know major was
running around by and he wasn't just
nipping at people because he was
startled he was shooting across the
driveway to attack people shooting
across 10 feet of room to go after
agents and biting the heck out of them
didn't he didn't didn't he hurt biden
himself like well buy that supposedly
wait wait wait
joe biden was bathing with showering
with his dog in the room
right no all right so
joe biden says he broke foot tripping
after shower when he pulled his dog's
tail yeah why was red light in the
bathroom
no why was the dog in the back i don't
know it's a german shepherd they they
are protected
they're going to be there he says the
story to be fair all right to be fair we
got the description originally from joe
biden it's not like jen's sad it's not
like jen sack it was out there like the
president uh saw his dog and tried to
grab his tail after a shower like job i
was like i saw my dog man
i grabbed his tail a little rascal it's
like it's one of the most funniest
things
it's hysterical
abiding quote no you guys should you
guys should look it up and listen it's
actually hysterical it's like one of my
it's one of the funniest things he said
that we overlooked the most funnily
accurate thing that joe biden has said
recently love it but you know but saki
gets out there and she says hey you know
it was a minor dog bite and the secret
you know we just got the emails secret
service agents were furious
you know look they're lucky they didn't
have to put the dog down it was that
crazy surprise they didn't man let me
read this he says quote what happened
was i got out of the shower actually can
you see that seamus yeah can you can you
joe biden that for us come on man yeah
yeah what happened was i i got out of
the shower
i got i got a dog and anyone who's been
around my house and nose
dropped little pup dropped a ball in
front of me
and for me
to grab the ball biden told cnn
journalist jake tapper in the first post
election interview with vice
president-elect kamala harris and i'm
walking through this little alleyway to
get to the bedroom and i grab grab the
ball like this and he ran
and i'm joking running after him and
grabbed his tail and what happened is
that he slid on a throw rug and i
tripped on the rug he slid on
that's what happened oh man not a very
exciting story he said he was running
down an alleyway so yeah this hallway he
says he got i maybe i should animate
this one we animated
that story because we animated the corn
pop story and helped a lot of people
understand it better we just used his
narration uh but yeah he's basically
saying he got out of the
he got out of the shower and his dog had
a ball so he started chasing his dog
with him i just want you to imagine this
right come on so so let's be fair the
dog must not have been in the bathroom
he because it doesn't say that but so so
joe
is he wearing a towel or did he get out
of the shower i was picturing with a
towel
i hope he had a towel on because well
originally i thought he climbed out of
the shower
naked he probably slipped in the shower
and broke his foot and now he's created
this stupid story he's like and what
happened was which is a sign of a liar
when they buy time you know in their
middle of a conversation long-time
journalist ron kessler reported that the
secret service complained about biden's
swimming habits as being
uh wildly inappropriate in the buff
wait what gross
really it's in the book you can do a lot
with that one sheamus i know that that
could be nice
i'm sure you can find the audio of him
telling the story i remember looking for
it a while ago because i had the same
idea this story was pointed out to me
and i couldn't believe that i missed it
when it happened so i was searching for
the audiobook i i think i had trouble
finding it um it might have just been
something he said to a reporter that was
quoted in the press and wasn't actually
filmed the reason i think you all can
find it send it to me i think he's lying
about the story is because if he's going
to tell a story about how he's chasing
his dog down the hallway and pulled his
tail and broke his foot why would he
bring up the shower part of it it was
completely irrelevant to the story so
obviously it was part of the story
the bigger the story the bigger the lie
that's that's the old saying so uh
typically among kids when they're lying
they try to they try to explain every
possible thing when in reality uh you
know it's like how did you break your
foot i was playing the dog i fell
yeah that's it i was like i fell playing
with the doug but the reality is 76 and
he slipped in the shower i mean that's
that's my guess i don't know that i
don't know whether he's lying or because
honestly i i one million percent believe
that this is something he would do do
you guys not think that joe biden would
like chase his dog
you want to know my favorite thing about
the story was the conspiracy theorists
who were who kept telling everybody when
was this this was uh december 3rd 2020.
the conspiracy theorists who are who
kept pushing you know the the election
stuff said that
he didn't really break his foot he's
hiding the ankle bracelet because oh
what yeah no joke so that's what they
were saying and my favorite was when
they started believing that joe biden
flipped and was now helping trump and he
was like it's just great people look at
a photo of biden with a hurt foot that's
what they think and i'm like dude he's
an old man he fell yeah that's funny
another reason i question is cause like
you saw what they did with fdr when he
was getting polio is like basically
making him paralyzed they hid that from
people for like years i believe i'm not
sure exactly how long but they didn't
want people to know the president wasn't
doing well they'll hide that there is no
plan i keep on saying there is no plan
really not
scary sad let's let's talk about that
wokeness stuff though so uh we got this
from cnn business netflix's world has
been turned upside down as stock plunges
35 i think it's actually at 37
and then we got this story from cnn
business the magic is gone for disney
investors this is from april 19th just
just yesterday and they say that netflix
has plunged more than 40 percent and
disney is down 15 percent ladies and
gentlemen i would just like to say
get what go broke
indeed well that's happening at netflix
they gave as much i don't know what the
actual deal was i've seen 12 i've seen
50 million dollars to the obama's
production operation
i had netflix on the other day
and who was pushed at me barack obama
putting out some globalist nice nonsense
about parks and conservation and all of
that and
you know i guess i'm not allowed to say
anything against national parks but the
point is it was propaganda they're
paying off a left-wing politician
who uh frankly brings nothing in terms
of creativity other than
political activism and so netflix is
focused on as you as you've highlighted
both in the fiction and non-fiction
categories
propaganda and people are turning it off
and there are all sorts of other reasons
for it but if you're going and
the biggest reason in my view
and i say this only half jokingly is
that half the movies aren't american so
you're going oh this movie looks good
turns out it's in a foreign language or
in an accent that's hard to follow
because of the subtitles and you don't
want to watch it so it's garbage it's
leftist and it's not as the quality
they're supposed to be what's with this
weird overlap between the left and
sexually inappropriate content for
children or about children i i you know
that's curious because it's funny
when people come out and they're like
hey we don't want teachers talking to
kids about these adult matters it's the
left specifically it freaks out and says
we are being attacked by the right and
i'm like
sixty percent of democrats agree with
these bills in florida and these other
states that kids should not be taught
this stuff but you've got uh big um
big mouth is that the show's right yeah
was just renewed for season seven you
know that show is
it is it is voiced by adults but it is
about children going through puberty and
engaging in overt apparently all those
things
for seven years they're going through
puberty i guess are they still in
puberty
they're just living really slow yo and
people who have not seen the show i i
like i've mentioned this before like i
think it's a messed up which is
disgusting i mean you've watched it i
saw a couple i saw like half an episode
at my friend's house yeah i walked out
of the room i couldn't it's just so
disgusting they're 12 they're like 11
and 12 and they're talking about having
sex they're not talking about it it's so
gross
yeah there's like a scene where the kid
goes into a stall and they this they
show it and i'm like what how is this so
close
south park did
you know similar lewd and crude jokes
and those i'm just like oh i'm not even
i'm not even saying it's gross like
spectacularly it's gross psychologically
it's i couldn't let myself even hear it
because it was twisted and cuties so
gross yep now so that's why i don't have
netflix i'm lying yeah absolutely not no
there's absolutely no way i'll ever have
netflix subscription um
i think part of it is that obviously you
know there are creepy people all over
the world and in all parties but if
you're a creepy person who wants to
normalize your disgusting sexual
perversions the democratic party has
made it perfectly clear that they are a
safe bet for you and i think it's not
that's radical because they don't have
the moral foundation of purity
yeah that's one reason so
uh for those that aren't familiar with
the moral foundations man i'm i always
try to get them off my head there's care
fairness loyalty
purity
liberty and uh what's one more is it
authority
or is authority and loyalty the same
thing
look it up what's it called again the uh
moral foundations jonathan height
h-a-i-d-t
so liberals when they they have this
moral foundations test you can take it
asks you questions some of these
questions are really disturbing
and it asks you like to what degree are
you okay with this thing right and it'll
be like there's one where it says
a daughter takes her father's old you
know war flag and use it as a rag to mop
the floor or whatever are you okay with
this
and so
these are the kinds of questions it was
authority as the sixth yeah yeah it was
a thought so it's liberty sanctity which
i believe is the purity yeah loyalty
fairness care and authority yes and you
said and that's five though liberty was
added liberty liberty yeah yeah that was
the sixth one yeah libertarians only
have liberty this is amazing yeah they
don't care about anything other than let
me do what i want be free uh liberals
only have care and fairness so if you're
if you're saying something like children
must be protected the sanctity of of
children and purity innocence etc well
you're probably not going to be a
liberal because they don't have that in
their minds they don't they don't
understand this as a world foundation so
when you look at the moral foundations
test there are some questions that are
like outright disturbing they're hard
about like teachers and kids i i don't i
mean i don't know if i would say it's
hard to say it's is that okay or not but
some of it's like
you know an uncle i didn't want to say
this i can't even say these things yeah
but
it's remarkable what someone would have
to say is okay in order to actually get
listed as a liberal thing because i i
get i get uh listed as like you know
libertarian left leaning or something
like that and these are these tests but
i have a balance of you know i i have
care and fairness is relatively high and
that kind of goes down i'm like that
kind of makes sense like cause i'm kind
of in the middle but you look at how
liberals rank and i'm like
what question did they say they were
okay with
because that's kind of weird because
they don't care about it well i've said
this before leftism is essentially a
synonym for social decay it's the word
that we use to describe it and when you
think about values like care and
fairness those are the easiest to make
subjective so there's no i mean that's
not fair or i care about this person
what does that really mean at bottom i
disagree a little bit i think i think
you know a healthy society has a left
and a right wing and the left is kind of
experimental in a sense where it is a
bit chaotic and and you could describe
it in extreme sense as decay but the
right is supposed to keep things in
check so the left can be like hey we
want to try this we want to try that and
the right says no no no okay
mayor marijuana legalization is
tolerable you know what i mean yeah so
where i disagree is that the the
foundation of the left in
where we get these terms is actually
from the french revolution what the left
was doing was be heading people
murdering them trying to like
fundamentally restructure the society in
extremely disastrous ways so i agree
that there are people in society who the
left would argue they identify with or
have monopoly over when you're talking
about creative people or folks who might
be willing to challenge the status quo
in some way but that's not what leftism
is that's some that's a good good
robespierre man you made a good point
there there are guys down at occupy wall
street who who there's like one dude who
said that he it was his dream to be
robespierre and i'm like you know he
died he got his jaw blown off and they
laid him on a table for two days to die
they love it man well i love the idea i
go back to the library cop on seinfeld
maybe dating myself but uh remember he
goes you know what's with you seinfeld
you want those pictures and kids to open
the book up and that's what gets you
going seinfeld and i think that's what
gets too many of the left going in terms
of discussions of sexual activity with
children and just like that i don't
believe in slippery slopes we we fall
off cliffs morally and just like that
this two past two weeks it's now a tenet
of a major political party in this
country
to promote sex talk
with young children in secret in school
in schools
and and to me that's not left right this
is a radical marxist agenda they want to
tear us away
from any competitor to their revolution
tariffs away from religion
from family
from private entities business
and your biology and and and sexuality
is traditionally understood and they
want to tear that away and put all of
that into a mix that they will impose
when convenient they'll tell you what
you're going to be and because you have
to rely on them because it's you're just
the cog in the revolution and anything
that gets in the way of that any
tradition or even biology they they're
able to they want to destroy this is
these are dangerous revolutionary times
using the word robespierre the
that figure it's not it's it's not
inappropriate yeah well and i want i'll
take it even further and be more clear
about it it's not just that they want to
have these conversations about sex with
children that would be bad enough that
would be a problem in and of itself but
they want to normalize
perverted sexual behaviors to children
in secret it's in secret so i i i think
um
i actually think schools should teach
religion
i think there should be like religious
studies
that's not to say they should tell kids
you should be this religion they should
just be like as part of our social
studies class like we're going to learn
about various religions but
to the extent that they're allowed to do
it i wonder because you can't have you
can't teach the bible in these schools
so i i jokingly tweeted i have jokingly
was like we should have religion studies
kids have questions teachers should be
allowed to give answers if a kid sees
the the crucifix or a rosary or
something on the desk well then the
teachers should be allowed to give
classroom instruction on christianity
right well of course the left would flip
out if that was the case then i added we
should also
teachers should also tell the kids to
keep it a secret from their parents like
that's just
unheard of
well i don't think the schools are
capable of doing that the left would
never allow it to happen and you know my
view is that
you have to
uh think about you uberizing
education
that you find out who's available to
give the your children the instruction
they need you may not be able to do it
through your own homeschooling program
but you have individuals out there who
say
you want this taught you want a third
grade education for your child pay me
for three months and we'll get it done
under your supervision and guidance and
you'll know what's being taught because
the public schools unless they are
validly conservative there's an old
conservative
truism
that says any organization not a validly
conservative becomes left over time
that's the thing and that's true
especially about this i don't like using
the word left it's they become radical
the opposite of conservative is radical
yeah the whole liberal thing has been
overutilized and you made that point
about going after kids
i don't see that as a left thing i see
that as a child predator thing and i
think child predators saw that they
could they could weasel their way in
with the left they tried it by doing the
lgbtp thing
the left rejected that initially and
they were like no no now you've got the
map thing minor attracted persons people
who want to go after kids no you're not
going to be able to accomplish that with
conservatives who have a moral
foundation around sanctity the only
option is to get people on the left to
agree without god anything is possible i
like that you mentioned care and
fairness and what it actually means and
how they're maybe misinterpreting it
because if you see a starving child and
you think well the way i can be care
care about this kid is to give them food
every day you create a dependence cycle
a good another good way to be care about
that kid is to teach him how to fish now
that kid can go and take care of himself
now what's the real sort of care is it
to feed that kid every day and make
basically a slave out of him to you or
to teach him how to become independent
both people there are two people tell
you that both of them are types of
caring but
getting too emotionally invested in i
think is where things can start to get
twisted so when you're you would need a
combination when dealing with a child
right so for example the responsibility
the parent is to provide for their child
and feed them but also as you mentioned
ensure that when they become an adult
they are capable of providing for
themselves uh that said
i think when you look at care and
fairness as i mentioned earlier you can
call anything caring or anything fair
it's what they do all the time i mean
look at their like tautological
reasoning around the normalization of
perverse behavior love is love what does
that actually mean that sounds very
caring that sounds very fair but it
doesn't actually mean anything you
haven't explained why this is behavior
that we should accept yeah sex they're
like sex is on the internet so we need
to tell kids about it early we care
about them you know if you really care
about your kids don't show them the sex
these things are a radicalization tool
you do not give them to children check
this out real quick this one from june
5th 2019 human events no snapchat love
definitely does have an age oh my gosh
so they're going to mention that so this
is actually saint claire who noticed
that on snapchat there was a sticker
that said love has no age
and everyone immediately was like yo it
does it's over 18. like what is this
there's lots of types of love firstly
there's eight types of love according
to one of them
and that is not for children we get it
there's like child love but it's
actually it it's it's interesting you do
mention the different kinds of love
because our culture we just use one word
for it and
i think part of the flaw here is that we
have taken this idea of love in the
sense of selfless giving and willing the
good of the other person and we've
conflated it with arrows with uh the
desire for sexual pleasure the reason
why i didn't want to derail into this
philosophical argument is it was
literally about lgbtq pride the stickers
on snapchat was about lgbtq issues and
it included love has no age
yikes all right dusting so they're not
talking about platonic love we're
talking about agape the love of the
community they're it's like you don't
know there's there's no ways to they're
not they're not they're talking about
people who want to get married to each
other that's erotic love arrows that's
what it's called yeah right so we i
don't i don't we don't need to well
they're using the word love to get you
to trick you into thinking that it's
about like familial love
no they aren't it's not love in the
metaphysical sense that's for sure
you're you you you love to talk about
loves different forms that is immaterial
here to what we're talking about when
you're talking about lgbtq we're talking
about issues of people who want to get
married and have relationships with each
other one of the words in there is
bisexual
when they say for lgbtq positive
branding love has no age there's no
reason to elaborate beyond that we know
what they're saying i agreed agreed well
i mean you have familial love your
mother loves you as a child when you're
born that's but that's not how they mean
well it's a different kind of they're
abusing their twist that's the problem i
mean you said it clearly that word is
too vague
love is too vague it's too good the
greeks had eight different types of it
why don't we well you know
getting back to the issue of the uh
the focus on the sexualization of
children
at the left in my view the organized
left the extremists left i'm not talking
about liberals i don't say think
liberals hate children but the organized
revolutionary left hates children they
hate childhood they have no use for it
other than as a prop for more government
and more revolution
so what else would you if you hated
children what would you do
well you traumatized them with sex talk
you'd kill them in the womb yep you you
do all sorts of things that the left is
doing and it and it's and to degree they
talk about childhood it's about
collectively raising children it takes
vitals to raise a child uh this is this
is not a child-friendly uh philosophy uh
this radical idiot it's fundamentally
anti-family i want to make sure we have
a little bit of good news here we uh you
know not always just complaining but we
have this story from the daily mail
former mcdonald's ceo who invented the
mcnugget good for him sets up new group
to fight back against woke corporations
and buys enough bank of america shares
to formally propose that firm scraps
staff crt training whoa
ed rensey who served as the ceo of
mcdonald's in the 1990s is partnering
with conservative groups to fight back
against corporations he formed the
boardroom
emit imitative a partnership between the
job creators network the free enterprise
group and second vote the goal of the
group is to protect shareholders and
employers of publicly traded companies
from woke policies and ensure corporate
accountability it comes as left-wing
groups continue to buy up stocks and
businesses until they raise enough clout
to lobby the board to adopt leftist
policies companies are also being forced
to the left so they can receive high esg
score
which would make them more profitable
i would argue this environmental social
governance thing they're doing via is
these companies that embrace this
violate their fiduciary duty to the
shareholders and the shareholders need
to start filing lawsuits and on that on
those grounds
well you know companies that do that uh
should be subject to scrutiny by the
feds and state authorities because you
know in some states
and and generally speaking the law is
when you're charged with investing
someone's pension money you're supposed
to be trying to maximize the return and
that's your priority
using it for other purposes
to end the oil industry or advanced
social agendas is
contrary to law
so it's not even a question of lawsuits
it's a question of are we going to have
law enforcement pursue these companies
and you've got these big companies like
blackrock
vanguard that are pushing this and
what's interesting is they push it here
but they're all they all own shares of
companies abroad they don't go they
don't go tell china companies chinese
companies you need to follow our our
woke agenda they tell american companies
so i think the concern conservatives
have to understand that corporations are
largely controlled by the left
and they're misusing and abusing our
funds and it's not a question of a
political difference it's a question of
misconduct
by the investors and as you point out
the corporations uh that are mismusing
dollars and misusing our retirement
dollars
misusing shareholder dollars and
misusing our retirement dollars
to advance a political agenda that goes
to go that's why florida is pulling back
disney's tax benefits because they're
misusing the the the the uh trust that
the public has given them through these
taxes conservatives are getting aided
now in the culture war by post liberals
people who were very much involved in
culture
and um arts but because the woke left
has gone so insane because they seem to
have no principles you have people
probably like us who all of a sudden are
just rejecting and opposing this one of
the challenges we face in all of this is
there are still people who don't realize
the shift and what has happened so you
still hear these old talking points
about republicans or pro corporation
it's like haven't you been around for
the past five years where the
conservatives were saying regulate big
tech because of censorship yeah at times
have it changed donald trump brought a
lot of people into the republican party
who are not traditional
or conservative in that capacity
and now
we need to find a way to get you know
people on the right who are still very
much like i don't want to regulate
corporations and we got to get people on
the left to realize they're being
screwed over by the corporations then we
can make those changes well it's not
regulation to enforce the laws against
fraud or against the misuse of dollar i
mean we're not asking for more i don't
want more regulation of twitter i just
want them to be held accountable for
lying to regulators and shareholders and
users in congress about the purpose and
the process of their censorship saying
goes for facebook and google and youtube
they're lying when they're saying
they're applying neutral principles and
there's an algorithm that can't be
messed with and don't worry it's equally
applied it's a big lie and if and and it
should be investigated as such the way
that the oil companies were being
investigated for quote lying about
climate change which was bunk but they
they we've got to enforce the law
against these companies if elon musk
gets a hold of twitter and that appears
to be the news right now that he's going
to be raising some money and making a
move within like the next week or so
he's going to get all those documents
well he doesn't need the weight to get
control he's as a shareholder he can ask
for documents about the processes that
i'm talking about how is it the decision
was made to throw off trump you know i
was blocked for a tweet i made about
hydroxychloroquine that was completely
accurate twitter had found it to be
accurate they someone complained about
it they said it's a violation of the
rules three four months later they
locked me out of my account for posting
the same darn tweet
i mean they're lying when they're saying
they're doing things neutrally you know
in a way that could survive scrutiny if
they would survive scrutiny we should
rely on elon musk to get the documents
out i i think that's an opportunity for
him to demand those documents as a
shareholder well i mean if we want to go
legally after these just corporations in
general for abusing their shareholder
trust that it would have to be a
decentralized move of law fair so
because if one unit like if you were the
only one to go then you're like
not a target like like they did when the
fbi goes into james o'keefe's house like
because he's because he's the head of
project veritas duh so like we need
everyone to go after it together and
maybe not that's obviously hyperbole but
we need enough people pushing against
these corporations for their fraud
narrative if there is such
that it's it's i mean this that's what
the the spirit of the united states is
decentralized movement yeah we're we're
in a great suppression i call it the
great suppression i mean where thought
is being suppressed
uh we have the biden administration
calling in big tech companies to
encourage them to censor people that's
right the big tech companies are doing
it i know judicial watch uncovered that
they were taking material down at the
behest of government agencies our
material other material
so i mean the idea that this is some
sort of private actor out there no it's
part of a it's collusion
and uh
it's a crisis in the sense that you know
we're in this revolutionary period
they want to suppress our speech
and yes they want to jail us as as james
o'keefe has found as those being
targeted by the january 6th committee
are fight is fine i mean that they're
now
taking the position that if you were on
an alternative slate of electors in the
disputed election you're being
investigated by the justice department
they want to jail their political
opponents this is a revolutionary period
and our republic is tottering
our republic is tottering absolutely
agreed i wanted to ask you something
about
the instance you brought up with the
white house actually instructing social
media companies to censor certain things
my understanding based on hearing that
is it sounds like a blatant first
amendment violation but i'm curious if
there's some kind of legal loophole
they're exploiting in order to get away
with this
well you know there's always legal
loopholes the question is are you going
to have
individuals in positions power to do
something about it actually exercise all
their prerogatives
so for instance president trump was
impeached for no good reason yeah there
are plenty good reasons to impeach biden
and i'm not seeing uh republican
leadership uh talking about that in any
significant way the justice department
is controlled by joe biden
the opportunities it seems to me in
terms of enforcement against these
companies is at the state level and you
know ron desantis is taking some
leadership roles there there are some
more aggressive attorney generals
at the state level as well who
understand going after twitter in texas
demanding documents during a big
document fight with twitter about their
censorship policies uh but it's got to
be coordinated i mean they're attacking
our freedoms and our civil rights and
our civil liberties and you know these
are god-given these are god-given civil
liberties our right to express our self
is is god-given it's not it's recognized
by the constitution but the right exists
separate and apart from it and
everyone's coming after it you said joe
biden is in control of the justice
department do you mean by appointing
judges
constitutionally speaking he's
controlled the justice department is his
appointees
the justice department is run by the
left it's a democratic
agency most of the agencies are
controlled by democrats and leftists and
the justice department is a locust of
evil when it comes to public policy in
our country every bad thing the
government does the justice department
defends it and or participates in it but
it's supposed to be a neutral entity
it's supposed to be an entity that
reflects the will of the people through
its appointed representative or elected
representative such as the president and
he has the justice department uh is run
by his attorney general and other senior
appointees are confirmed by the senate
so there are those checks in place
but the agency tends to do what it wants
to do and if there's a democrat in
office
they're free and clear and if they're a
republican in office
they're still free and yeah they used to
be at each other like john adams and
thomas jefferson man they would just
argue they'd get up there and think i'm
your vice president because i don't
agree with you and we're not going to
screw this up no it's not a cult so i'd
like to ask you
what's our way out of this
well you know i i always tell people you
know all you can do is what you can do
are you doing what you can do are we
using all the tools available to us
under the constitution our system of
government to
enforce the rule of law and protect our
rights and liberties are we doing what
we can do at the state level are you
active individually with your party if
these issues concern you are you
communicating with your elected
officials and your friends and your
colleagues
are you running for office are you
participating in the party mechanics you
can complain about the republican party
but if you're not participating some
loser is probably participating who's in
it for all the wrong reasons and then
once they're elected we need men and
women of ambition who understand their
role in history and
to protect our republic and to say we're
not turning over
the reins of our government to unelected
bureaucracies
we're not going to play this game where
we sign a check once a year for four
trillion dollars and then see what
happens and then complain about it after
the fact it's like you know the
government you know congress is like uh
the guy who says you know the
firefighters who set a fire
and then show up after the house burns
down and starts complaining well this is
terrible you mentioned they're all
responsible you mentioned january 6 and
we do have this story which just came
out a couple hours ago on twitter
everyone is uh people are are saying
that alex jones has flipped
according to the new york times alex
jones reached out to the justice
department about a january sixth
interview
they say that uh through his lawyer mr
jones said he has given the government a
formal letter conveying his desire to
speak to federal prosecutors
the lawyer norm pattis maintained that
mr jones had not engaged in any criminal
wrongdoing that day
when chanting slogans about 1776 as a
condition of being interviewed by
federal investigators mr jones who is
known for his rants about the deep state
and is supposed to is supposed to
control and its supposed control over
national affairs has requested immunity
from prosecution huh the first thing i
would say is i don't trust the new york
times on stories like this but the other
thing i would i would say too is
everyone's saying you know it's a lot of
people left they're like he's flipped
i'm like
alex jones is on video yelling people
not yelling at them not to go near the
capitol that was a trap not to go in
he's not going to get immunity from
prosecution first of all there are no
crimes that are being pursued here other
than perhaps against some of the january
6 defendants who actually committed
violent acts in violation of the law the
alex jones of the world to the degree
they're facing any liability it's
because of corrupt
prosecutions or activity by the fbi doj
and the democrats in congress pushing
them and you know my understanding of
the federal system is that you don't get
immunity
what they do is you plead guilty to a
crime
accept a punishment that might be
mitigated as a result of your
cooperation they don't give out
typically immunity for crimes they let
make you plead guilty so you know my
guess is alex jones wants to roll the
fbi and tell him the truth and tell him
the truth about uh what he did and you
know i believe he didn't do anything
wrong
but
you know so
the people who believe the the most
psychotic conspiracies about january 6
believe in saying conspiracies about
what this is right now he's flipping oh
man he's there he's going to read on
trump the [ __ ] yeah that's the crazy
talk that there's something to flip over
yeah right exactly so uh we had this
this really fun moment in january where
i said that uh
the people who were you know waved in to
the capitol or who walked up and the
cops opened the doors and said you know
let him come in and said i respect your
right to protest and took selfies with
with them these people it's it's how are
you going to pro how do you get how are
you going to get them on trespassing how
are you going to get them on you know
trespassing in the capitol if they're
invited in you won't be able to do it
and the young turks
did this segment where they were like
tim poole is so dumb he's so dumb and
then what did we see there's actually uh
a guy got the charges dismissed because
he was like they let me in the judge was
like you're right they did have a nice
day good sir
so i imagine
there's a lot of people
who obviously the ones that were
fighting there was one guy who got his
charges dismissed relating to like
mischief and vandalism or something but
he got trespassed because the judge was
like yo you climbed over something to
get in there you knew you were
trespassing so there's we're going to
see the people who are violent get
charged we're going to see the people
who are let in probably a lot of these
people are going to start getting you
know
not guilty pleas or or not not guilty
verdicts
but the people on the left who are
seeing the story right now because
they're tweeting about it
this is the exact same thing as the
people who thought trump was was going
to show up on march 3rd or whatever and
walk into the white house and that joe
biden ankle bracelet or whatever and
arrest and arrest everyone yeah right
yeah and it ain't going to happen and
you know the real scandal is contin you
know we've sued for all the records uh
all the videos of the capital we sued
the congress for it we're in court nancy
pelosi's congress is telling us that
they have sovereign immunity meaning
they're immune from lawsuit
and none of the record they're not
public records and even if they were the
public interest doesn't require their
release so it's the worst day in
american history but there's no public
interest in releasing the records so you
know in my experience when you don't
want to release one second of video
even voluntarily
what are you hiding
and i'm sorry guys but you know this
whole michigan collapse the whitmer
kidnapping collapse means we should take
a look at if the fbi would break the
rules there
did they break the rules in some of the
january 6 activities and i suspect we're
going to find out that's the case
absolutely i mean look
anyone who knows the name ray epps can
tell you that there was almost certainly
foul play here and we should just say to
them what they've been saying to us over
the fact that they've been collecting
people's data in bulk if they have
nothing to hide then they should have
nothing to fear release the tape show us
what happened reps is interesting he was
a dude at the a rally whatever you want
to call it event january 16. and he was
like yelling for people to go to the
capitol i believe and they started
calling him a fed they everyone started
yelling at him
and then all of a sudden he disappears
and he's not prosecuted is this right he
turns up in a bunch of videos
encouraging people and inciting them to
riot and not prosecuted with the amount
of spy tech we have can you how's that
guy not being prosecuted what about the
the guy who planted the bombs they
didn't find that person never found that
that story just disappeared yeah just
completely disappeared well and and
supposedly harris is in the neighborhood
yes harrison didn't find it what the
heck is going on they said kamala harris
was right there that morning but then
they just stopped looking for the guy
who planted them apparently i mean god
help us you know i hate to get back to
the secret service you know they get
attacked you know the agents were
attacked for complaining about being
attacked by dogs we found out the secret
service top people or people in the
position to protect the president
were being targeted with a scam some
type of fraud
uh by these two uh shysters in
in uh in dc they were offering them
gifts and the secret service didn't even
figure out what was going on i think it
was the postal inspection service that
figured it out so the secret service is
kind of is as dysfunctional and as
someone who doesn't want to see
anyone in a position of power harmed in
the worst possible way i worry about our
security in the look january 6
highlights that we can't the government
can't protect us they blew the security
on january 6 the capital
the secret service is just this side is
just of dysfunctional
and these are major issues i mean why is
it we think the secret service is any
better than any other government agency
olivia rondo went on kennedy nation and
said something really profound and i
hope i get this right olivia it's that
the government is there to serve us not
to take care of us
remember that you're here to serve us we
put you there on purpose so that you can
work for us and get this done right
because we're all sovereign that's
that's i i you're right but at this
point in our country in the past hundred
years
it's just like
dude that's just not the case anymore
but that's the american spirit without
it that's that's the nature that the com
the country is just a piece of land
where people are getting along next door
to each other if we don't have that
belief in common then
things can go pretty hard we are seeing
in in cities
democrat-controlled cities non-citizens
being granted the right to vote
the moment that happens you don't have a
country
like it's happening
the uh the the uh presidential election
the electoral college is influenced by
non-citizens
for uh uh i think there was you know one
or two votes in favor of democrats
because of the amount of illegal
immigrants in california or something
like that
the congressional seats are not
uh apportioned based on citizen count
they're based on population count so if
you have a million non-citizens in one
area they're going to get an extra
congressional seat and an electro an
extra electoral vote
these things are ripping they're it's
it's we're a ship we're a big a big
cruise ship those things are holes in
the ship and we are taking on what i'm a
realist do you think that we're just
headed towards globalization and we got
to figure out how to roll with it oh
well yes absolutely okay i think so the
issue is
uh
to a certain degree
globalization is not a bad thing the bad
thing is the authoritarian takeover and
the destruction of our sovereign our
sovereignty you can have international
agreements we can do away with war we
can have this beautiful planet but in
this area we have our own laws we make
our rules we live to according to our
values and things like that
the problem is the world economic forum
doesn't like our values the davos group
doesn't like our values the values they
want for the world are more like china's
yeah i don't want to live that way so
that's the real problem is uh you know
we had elad aliyahuwan and he said he
likes a unipolar world he doesn't want
china to gain influence he wants the us
to dominate everything because our
values are better and i'm like he's
being honest about it and and we need to
recognize that in the world of the uh
the globalization as it's colloquially
understood is
style social credit systems
we can have a kind of international
relations that can you know end war and
have international courts where we
retain our sovereignty and our values
are persist do you think we're really
ever going to end war
so i think what likely would happen is
we may have already done it in the
traditional sense of how we we've we've
known it or be getting really close to
it
uh obviously ukraine and russia right
now there's hot war
but
will we break past that point where it
is just not economically feasible or
worth going to war instead you'll see
shady dealings soft power manipulation
or fifth generational warfare so war
conflict will always exist in some form
but when we're talking about modern
warfare and we get to the point where
we're like kinetic warfare is fading
away and now it's all manipulation games
it'll be psychological manipulation well
you know this is this is uh ukraine is
kind of the uh highlights that war is a
feature of the human condition and you
know we spent trillions of dollars in
our national security apparatus
uh the diplomacy usaid
obviously that our defense and
intelligence establishments to prevent
war in europe
and it happened
in a harpy
and you know and i think you could argue
because of what we've spent ukraine
isn't luxembourg it has 45 million
people so this is not an insignificant
military action by the russians and we
we paid these guys to stop crap like
that from happening and they couldn't
figure out how to stop a gangster
from going down the block and breaking
someone's window you know and i'm
exaggerating obviously for effect there
but putin was stoppable and my view is
this is where the corruption comes home
to roost he sees biden his cognitive
challenges he knows biden's on the take
because he's on the taken part from
russia based on the information that's
out there so he sees a corrupted and
firm repub
leadership in in our country and why not
do what he did
i'm not saying it was the reason he did
it but some of the stoppers that would
have been in place as a result of a
competent strong america that wasn't
corrupted weren't the present
and to me that's the result is death and
destruction in ukraine
yeah man that's why integrity is so
important as an individual and as a
nation all of it because if you if you
are no longer your word is no longer
good
no one's going to take you seriously we
had documents i love these documents we
found because you know i go back to them
all the time and there were these
documents just before biden uh before
trump came in biden went and visited
ukraine and the two top state department
officials in ukraine are talking about
his visit the anti-corruption visit and
these were the two officials who
testified against trump and they were
talking three days before trump came in
that biden's there and the russian press
is making fun of biden's anti-corruption
issues
because his son is on barisma and they
said that trump the russians were
trolling biden and they
and the state department guy goes
barista is the gift that keeps on giving
so you know we've got the state
department telling themselves they're
making fun of our country our foreign
policy objective let's say neutrally was
to stop corruption in ukraine was being
hampered by the vice president's family
corruption and we're supposed to forget
that when ukraine is invaded uh four
years later i think when obama said
never uh what is this all about never
never overlook the bidens of joe's
ability to screw something up he said
something along those lines he wasn't
joking yeah
he didn't say screw he used the
[Laughter]
joe biden screws up words
i mean it's just it's an apparently
familial board corporate uh relations in
ukraine too
the hunter should have never been on
that board man that's nuts
yeah the challenge we face internally is
tribalism there are people who have
built careers off pandering and they
won't give it up it's true on the right
it's true on the left but i think what
you have right now going on for the
right is that like i mentioned in the
post liberal types people who were
democrat voters before who are more
interested in principle and integrity
are sitting here being like
look
i can watch ben shapiro ben shapiro will
be like joe biden was engaged in corrupt
behavior in ukraine and i'm like
and right okay he's invading
okay joe biden did bad things in the
account i think it's really quite
obvious based on the tape we've seen
thank you sheamus and uh and and i'm
sitting here and i'm like he's
completely right
and then he'll come out with you know
some political position on policy as
like as a response and i'm like well i
disagree on your your response position
like but if we agree on the facts
that's what's happening
any any sane reasonable person knows joe
biden was is crooked and doing crooked
things
i mean flying his son on air force two
to china for a private equity deal why
are using our resources for that but
you'll get these people on the left who
are just like didn't happen
didn't happen that's why they won't come
on this show are you invited on the show
because they know we'll sit down and
i'll pull up all of the stories and all
of the videos and they'll have to sit
there and and listen to it and then
they're gonna have no choice when people
are when their fans are watching and
like
i didn't know that
it's like well because they didn't tell
you you know i never understood well i
guess i do understand but politicians of
both party always misunderestimate is
that the right word uh
misunderestimate that's right that's a
man i i've almost forgotten about i'm
double on doubling down on
underestimating it
the the corruption is is a driving force
for so much of the electoral public you
know i do you remember when nancy pelosi
came and took over congress in 2010
you know what her her uh
her big piece was her big slogan we need
to drain the swamp huh yeah so you know
and what happens is these politicians
run on battling corruption in washington
dc
of both parties and then they get here
and it doesn't get done
and in the case of trump he actually did
want to do something and none of his
appointees thought it was important
republicans don't care about battling
corruption i know there are exceptions
and the exceptions prove the rule
democrats have incorporated corruption
unfortunately into their governing
governance style
they turn their offices in the case of
the vice president uh uh into a a
racketeering operation so this is um
this to me
there's opportunities on both sides of
the political aisle to run on a reform
anti-corruption agenda with teeth yes
but i do think republicans have their
degree of corruption as evidenced by
this story from timcast.com candidate
robbie starbuck responds to being kicked
off tennessee ballot starbuck told tim
cast he is exploring every legal option
to remain in the congressional race
that's right
they tried passing this law to bump him
and another individual off the ballot by
saying that it lived there long enough
turns out robbie actually did live in
this district long enough now i guess
they're claiming he's not a republican
what robbie starbuck morgan ortegas and
baxter lee were all disqualified from
the upcoming primary after the parties
vote on april 19th that they did not
meet its standards for bona fide
republicans their candidacy was
challenged earlier this month triggering
a vote by the state election committee
according to the bylaws a candidate is
required to have voted in three of the
last four republican primaries or have
state republicans vouch for them quote
the idea that i am not a republican is
most offensive because if i am not who
the hell is starbucks said
starbuck uh he apparently said let me
see if i can find the quote that he's
been uh the 30 33 year old said he had
14 vouching letters affirming his status
as a republican including statements
from several county party chairs and the
leader of the nashville young
republicans he was also endorsed by u.s
senator rand paul in 2021 wow starbuck
largely attributed the party's vote to
institutional corruption believing that
republican leaders in the state would
prefer a controllable rhino right this
is how the system works in order to get
into office it's through one of the two
parties
the parties are private organizations
who can do whatever they want so they're
blocking robbie starbuck from being able
to run because he's a real candidate
well and this goes to my point so there
are probably a lot of conservatives in
tennessee and we may presume well you
know tennessee that's got to be
conservative down there well that
republican party leadership has been a
long time moderate
um operation i mean the
republicans from tennessee at least in
the senate haven't been as hardcore as i
would have liked and this is why people
should participate in party politics
you know you can't you can't spit from
the outside and expect the party to
change if you're a democrat get involved
in democratic politics if you're a
republican get involved in republican
politics if you don't
that's what happens yeah i wonder if
it's also because of nashville being in
tennessee whenever you have a large
urban center like that it skews your
elections to the left and you get uh you
get
fake republicans yeah
well rob is definitely a republican i
know the guy i've looked him in the eyes
i mean i'm kind of being facetious
no well okay
what he is what you just said for people
to get into politics i cannot fathom how
to fix the system from within the system
because the system is busted it's like
being on a broken train that's about to
go off a cliff if you have the chance to
fix it from above and you can actually
see the whole train and fix the tracks
now we're talking but if you want to get
on board man how can you fix
the train and the tracks from inside
well it's the same thing about the
school board fight you can't you can't
you know you have to be at the table in
order to affect the debate and you show
up at these meetings they're usually
boring
and you just you show up at political
meetings and that you know a lot of
people don't
and if you do and you're principled you
can go far and because people need
bodies and before you know it you're the
county chair before you know it you're
on the state executive committee of the
party and before you know it you're in a
position to certify someone like robbie
starbuck onto onto a ballot or oppose
someone who shouldn't be on the ballot
so it works both ways and you know we
want the parties to be strong
our establishment wants the parties to
be weak
and and to kind of have a vanilla flavor
throughout the system and if you want
distinctions and you want activism you
got to learn how to win i mean that's
the and
way to do that is by participating in
the process you need activism
the left is really good at organizing
phone call and postcard letter campaigns
what are what are republicans going to
do right now after what they're doing to
these candidates namely robbie starbuck
because this is bs
they're just lying saying he's not a
republican so that they can boot him off
the ballot well every republican needs
to figure out how to organize
every individual who believes in robbie
starbuck and is sick of the corruption
in in this machine staring in the face
of it needs to get organized and figure
out something because i'll say what the
left would do they wouldn't stop calling
you you'd you would get 50
leftists and they would just hit the hit
redial and then wait for the phone to
answer and then start complaining when
they hang up hit redial again and their
phones would be off the hook and just 50
people
yeah i mean each leftist has all 50 of
their personalities call in to complain
right that's right all their head mates
yeah yeah i just wanted to say before we
move on from this topic is that one of
the best ways that you can do this kind
of activism is to call your local gop
like if you're in tennessee listening to
this you should talk to the gop there in
tennessee and tell them that you're not
okay with this they're crooked people
people need to protest yeah volunteer
and you know for instance on the
election systems if you don't like the
way elections are run
go and participate in running elections
you can get hired i mean you you know
the unions you know they they're gonna
get hired they make it a point to get
higher to count votes well republicans
and conservatives should make it a point
to be hired and count votes
that's the way to ensure that elections
are more fairly run
actually count the votes well according
to the law
at the time we have a corporation
tallying the votes in private which is
dominion for the last presidential
election which is incredibly disturbing
i think we need to also in addition what
you're saying tom build a parallel
system where you can vote in their
system and vote in this system that's
transparent and see if it lines up no
yes no ian well no and you know what we
have to do
we have to free the code you're right a
big a big tech big technology firms that
are functioning in the commons their
code needs to be free this is the free
this is the freedom of speech at the 20
we need to free the software code of the
voting machines yeah i need to be able
to reference those these companies that
are doing digital vote counting that
code needs to be public and it and and
here's what needs to happen
before the election
uh uh there there should be a an audit
where
a person from each you know party and an
independent
goes in with an approved you know tech
person who then
audits the code and presents it to the
public and says here's how the code of
this machine works
every single every single line is
available for public viewing i feel like
even then it could they could give you
the code and say this is how it works
but then go in the back room and make it
do other things sure
so you need it on a blockchain too
honestly i think they're bold enough
that they would show you the actual code
and if anyone pointed out any problems
with it
fact check false there is no problem
with the code it's not a conspiracy
theory no no because uh remember when
democrats were screaming there was going
to be fraud in the election like in 2019
or something they were like we got to do
something about this and then they all
started shutting up when you have before
an election and no one knows how things
are going to swing
you see one thing wrong and the democrat
is gonna be like no no and the
republicans gonna be like no no fix it
fix it we we object
because unless someone's in on it well
my view on these companies dominion and
smartmatic you know they've come up with
these outrageous lawsuits against
critics
that seem to be mighty political and
over the top
and you know we want these companies to
be neutral right and it seems to me
they've thrown down the gauntlet on one
side of the political narrative when it
comes to our elections and i would be
very suspicious whether their code works
or not
about letting them work in any states
yeah the thing that they're going after
is people
claiming that they're fraudulent i'm not
making that claim i'm claiming that i
can't see the code so i don't know if
it's fraudulent or not well i i think i
think whether you see the code or not is
almost irrelevant to the question of
are we counting ballots in a way that
people are confident that the
individuals casting the ballots are
eligible to vote
and i don't think that's true whether if
the code works
you know illegal votes
will be counted accurately but i think
that's not going to solve the problem
i'm not i'm not
the issue is so much deeper than just
i guess i suppose illegal voting because
you can track those things down but if
california opens their border up and
says come on in and then the census
happens and they're like look how many
how many more people we get and they get
more votes in the electoral college it
doesn't matter if the individual votes
all that matters is we know texas will
be blue and taxes can can effectively
stuff the electoral college ballot
by bringing in non-citizens you know the
system should be set up in a way to uh
and i think you're highlighting the
issue
to reassure people that their votes are
going to be counted and counted
accurately and the election result is
going to be something approximate to the
actual
what actually happened the winner won
whether it's exact or not the winner won
and right now
half the country doesn't think that's
the system and so we need to reassure
the public we need to save elections
by requiring voter id
maybe getting rid of the computer
counting or make it a lot more easily
watchable uh and uh having one day only
voting
only emergency uh absentee voting if
you're getting your head shot off abroad
and you're in the military maybe yeah
that that warrants you getting a special
treatment everyone else show up or but
the idea that you're voting out there
without any supervision any party
looking at you to make sure you're not
being intimidated or outside the
protection of the of security and our
government processes it's an open
opportunity for fraud and when people
don't have confidence in the system the
system collapses
well i'll put it this way if uh
someone invited you over to their house
in you know the middle of a big city
like chicago chicago is a good example
and uh they said you can crash here
we have no doors or windows all like
they're basically just all exposed and
open
and uh no no one will like we've we've
never like you know filmed anybody
coming in here so you know we don't
think it's an issue would you be
comfortable like chilling in there and
leaving your stuff
and going to bed you're like no i don't
i'm going to keep my bag close to them
i'm going to wrap my arms around the
backpack as i go to sleep because you'd
be like i'm not okay with this it's not
an issue of whether or not someone did
or or
is in the act of committing an illegal
act it's that
why would you want to participate in an
insecure system like hey come crash at
my house while you're in chicago the
doors the front door and the back door
are completely off the hinges and the
windows have all been removed but you
can sleep wherever you want you'd be
like nah i'm good or you go to the bank
and they've got black paint over all the
cameras and you give cash to someone
standing out front who says don't worry
i'll get it to the teller and the teller
doesn't keep any records who gave it to
the money and where the money's supposed
to be going you know when you've got us
you have to have a system in place that
survives basic scrutiny it ain't going
to be perfect i mean we we were doing an
analysis of voter roll lists in new york
and
california oregon in new york i think
they removed ten names in the entire
city over the last four years they
should have removed hundreds of
thousands of names so you've got the
list are full of people who have moved
away
and that's just like a big pool of
voters
to pull from illegally to engage in
fraud and that undermines the system and
and the courts have found interestingly
tim that you don't need the proof fraud
in order to justify these rules
it's the appearance of fraud and the
opportunities for fraud that states have
an interest in stopping to reassure
voters that your vote's going to be
counted so the left says you don't you
don't we don't have to prove fraud
in order to justify voter id
and to make sure that people are
actually citizens for instance before
they're allowed to vote which is to me
the
voter id everyone agrees with well it
doesn't work if citizen non-citizens can
get that type of voter id that allows
them to vote yeah i want to do a i want
to mention this story because we did we
did miss it and we shouldn't have but uh
julian assange extradition order issued
by london court moving wikileaks founder
closer to u.s transfer
the the difficult thing with the story
on julian assange is i called it a
political execution what that what i
mean by that is
the goal of everything they did with
julian assange
putting him in lock up
you know he's he gets jammed up in in
how in the ecuadorian embassy is just to
end his ability to work
they can't you know there's that thing
where hillary clinton was like can we
just drown the guy when he was like in
london or something but uh
it's an important story and we need to
uh just i want to make sure we keep it
in the spotlight to the best of our
abilities as this stuff is going on
because what happened to julian assange
is the most one of the most corrupt
and overt displays of evil that we have
seen from
our and other governments to silence
somebody who was a thorn in their side
i think the justice department and the
fbi are irredeemably corrupt and that
means that even charges against people
who may have done something wrong
especially in a political context
can't be trusted and it's a horrible
situation to be
uh for a country that respects the rule
of law when it's top enforcement
agencies that put their thumb on the
scales all the time
the liberal economic order really
changed this country now they're using
it as like the spearhead of a military
global military force and it's like be
damned the consequences that like he
exposed collateral murder with wikileaks
and you see these like helicopter pilots
laughing as they're blowing up civilians
and they weren't laughing they were
joking with each other and like go get
them yeah yeah and uh
and that's we i think as a human maybe
we didn't need to see it but it woke a
lot of people up to the fact that there
is a liberal economic order in a
military-industrial complex for better
or worse
i don't know man i don't know well let's
go to super chats if you have not
already hit that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show share the
url or just tell your friends about it
it really does help and become a member
at timcast.com to support the work of
our journalists and you will also get
access to exclusive segments of this
show coming up around 11 or so pm so
we'll have one of those up for you
tonight again timcast.com and smash that
like button let's read we've got gbp who
says happy420 and he put an emoji of
fire and broccoli a person with their
mouth open and smoke
broccoli
well i guess it's as close you can get
on the emojis right i figured out the
history of 420. most credible story
traces to four april 20th marin county
california 1971
five students at san rafael high school
would meet at 4 20 p.m yes uh by the
campus statue of chemist louis pasteur
to partake they chose that specific time
because extracurricular extracurricular
activities had usually been ended by
then yeah
path of least resistance memotype says
ian halfway through your michael malus
appearance you're an incredible person
and a genuine light in the world much
love thank you so much man and i was
going to shout out to the other show
i'll do it now i was on your welcome
with michael males at drop today 420
what's up michael uh it was epic that
guy
is is like otherworldly he's an
incredible interviewer kind soul a
beautiful man intelligent person i
highly recommend going to check it out
you're welcome on youtube michael malus
subscribe leave a comment let let me
know what you think about our show there
michael mouse is one of our favorite
people absolutely all right titus
flavius josephus says aimed primarily at
tim but curious of everyone's answer is
being authoritarian always evil in your
opinion or would you side with an
authoritarian that is generally aligned
with you use authority to maintain
liberty uh being authoritarian is not
always evil but it's not about
maintaining my alignment it's about
the the uh how it's wielded right so
in an emergency
where you're facing a very serious
existential threat and legitimate one
i think it's fair to say that we take
extreme measures the problem is
that is exploited
for political gains and then if you give
the government the ability to seize
power with an emergency they will make
up emergencies to cease power
so
i think there are instances where
and and it's tough because authoritarian
could mean a couple different things in
the context but adhering to authority
isn't always bad it's varying degrees
for me i'm way down on the libertarian
spectrum but i am not at the bottom i'm
not an anarchist i recognize some
authority is actually a really good
thing and it helps people live safely
and securely but when you start getting
into the more overtly and over
authoritarian is when you get evil
corruption etc so i don't know if you
guys want to yeah i'm thinking of
dungeons and dragons alignment you got
lawful neutral and chaotic and you know
i think what you were saying earlier is
that you're neutral in that because you
see the value of law but you also see
how dangerous it can be when it's used
improperly sometimes laws are very evil
like you have a lawful and you got to
break the law like thomas jefferson's
very very direct about that if if law is
misused it's our duty to make a new form
of law
well law that's evil isn't law so you
know to a degree we have the rule of law
and the authority arises from the rules
law is properly understood and
legitimate
that's appropriate but authoritarianism
in kind of the traditional political
sense is at odds with self-government
and that's almost always wrong
all right thomas sidebottom says tim one
of your videos convinced me today to
delete my netflix account then i bought
a subscription to the daily wire and
timcast.com right absolutely but you
what we need to do
instead of telling everybody cancel your
disney cancel your netflix we should be
like start making shows
start becoming members of of of channels
and companies that you do like like tim
cast or like daily wire
so we are we are uh we've got our mobile
app is coming out soon it's i so we're
first testing you know iphone then we
got to test android
then we want to do um
ott over the top so
roku apple tv it's you know all those
things so that we can make more shows
and just have them on that app so
instead of me being like you should get
rid of netflix i'll be like you should
just use our app instead and we're going
to make non-woke content yeah you're a
competitor you know this is the thing we
compete judicial watch competes against
netflix
libs of tick tock competes against the
washington post
we are competitors
so
you are supporting you know someone who
competes against those entities when you
support tim cat when you support
judicial watch when you support everyone
here at the table you're supporting
competition
in the information space
right on waffle sensei says i don't mind
if disney has its own government
operating on their property as long as i
can have my own personal government on
my property as well
well some would say you already do
just uh just get a hundred people and
you a hundred people i need to
incorporate a town right i don't know
what the rules are passing laws set make
it make speed traps
can you have a corporation of 100 people
and then turn it into a town i have no
idea
maybe maybe that's what what will happen
if you go to new jersey you'll find out
how many people can cause it you know
there's a town every three minutes
well out here in west virginia the issue
is they use the town as the postal
identifier but there's no there's no
town it's like a random house in an
unincorporated part of the state
scott odum says tim even if the
buildings aren't up to code they're
grandfathered in as existing buildings
but if they ever remodel they're in
trouble
well that will be really interesting
jason belch or bellick sorry
i'm a member and 25 year coder and
technologist which email do i use to
talk to you guys about possibly working
together members pitches i i think uh
spin the ufo sure i can pass that on to
whoever needs to get yep
so we have a lot of super chats asking
about gonzalo lira
and a lot of super chats but
they're all just saying he went missing
so we we did mention that a little a
little a while ago this the daily beast
contacted the ukrainian government to
alert them and now he's gone missing
i don't know who that is
he was a pickup artist like a dating
coach guy youtuber i think he's uh he's
not from the united states i believe but
he was an american citizen went to
ukraine making videos
talking about the war and then this
article comes out of the daily beast
that took some of his content out of
context like quoting him and make kind
of really the article makes him seem
like a putin apologist and that he
wanted russia to win the war or
something and then he just went
disappeared
man
all right dangerous dangerous times yeah
they message your government during a
war that's for sure simulation 115 says
tim have you heard of the fuster cluck
that is new york state's redistricting
what's going on there is crazy have you
been following that i have and i think
it it got fixed a little bit
what's been going on
you know what happened is you had the
democratic majority in new york
basically throw out all good sense and
issue an extreme partisan gerrymander
and the court's
last time i checked looked a scance at
it and threw it out but i'm not sure
what the status is now
we had a big fight in maryland over that
we just we beat back maryland's democrat
super majority court found it to be
extreme partisanship and we won
so you know it's fun you can't you know
you can win in these blue states if
you're principled and you're following
you know the rule of law is a glorious
thing in this country which why the left
hates it because it keeps them in
control
or within control
all right
captain uh what does it say captain
tanker joe says hey guys i want all of
your opinions on something why does
public school push college so badly it
seems like the public school system is
pushing people away from the trades to
brainwash the generations into debt
thoughts
so i have a couple thoughts here i would
say
firstly it's a system which is set up to
have a person continue to exist within
the system so a lot of young people
become teachers and it's basically
because they've never really considered
going out and doing something else also
maybe this is a little more cynical and
i'd probably like to flesh this out uh
more i don't know that this is their
intention but in fact i would say it
probably isn't but i find it interesting
that it helps them to abdicate their own
responsibility to prepare children for
the world so what we constantly hear is
people who have a high school diploma
aren't able to get a job
and perform at the level our economy
requires to the point where they could
earn a living and support a family so we
should give them four more years of
education for free instead of going hold
on what has gone wrong in the 12 years
of education that's already being
provided that they're not fully formed
adults who are able to compete in the
workforce for decent jobs school's
broken exactly public school is a
disaster
all right
let's see i want to say fundamental like
i completely fundamentally disagree with
the idea of it too i'm not saying we're
going to make it work top down see
anything for the most part is is pretty
risky yeah all right cesar 7 hill says
what is the show's opinion on a
childless tax to stimulate the birth
rate
um more like a family tax cut yeah the
more kids you have you get tax cuts yeah
i'd rather not punish people for living
single lives
i mean
you implement a high income tax then you
say we're doing a tax cut for people
with families and you're doing that
either way well you know
those who don't have kids
aren't paying in the long run for their
support through the social security it's
true so you're you're in many ways
childless folks are
not providing
enough tax revenue over the long term by
bringing in a new generation to support
their social security and other benefits
they get in the older years that's
absolutely correct not enough people
talk about that it the social security
system completely defers responsibility
so people don't end up having children
and raising families
grant arnett says earlier today you said
you're going to see doctor strange but
why see it after the laundry list of
reasons not to
there's a challenge but it's like i'm
saying i don't think we should go to
people and tell them to give up the
content they like abandon delete your
netflix
we should be saying create alternatives
and then once the daily wire has a
competitor we tell people you know make
sure you're supporting them as well
competition is more important i think
it's unreasonable to tell people
stop watching you know this show or that
show if you like it because people want
entertainment what we need to do is
compete and win that being said there's
great reasons to avoid disney absolutely
i think we also don't want to isolate
ourselves from the culture which is why
we have pop culture crisis on tim cast
it's not there's no real perfect answers
but my view of this is
we want to engage with the culture and
be a part of it and then pull people
towards our sphere of influence to
change things with the culture we create
with the culture we are participating in
and part of it is i just absolutely love
doctor strange and want to see the movie
so
recognizing that i can't expect to go to
someone and say give up all of your
favorite movies don't watch star wars
don't watch marvel don't watch any of
that stuff no that's unreasonable what
is reasonable is to be like the daily
wires got a superhero movie watch that
because at the very least then you're
supporting daily wires expansion
if you really want to you know go full
ideological then get rid of all that
stuff for sure
i think the reasonable approach is to
maybe tone it down and maybe give more
to people you do yeah you're practicing
mental jujitsu with people and they are
coming at you when you're in a
conversation with someone they're coming
at you telling them to stop coming at
you is not going to stop them you need
to move their energy into a new place
personally i can't keep track of
everything i'm supposed to boycott and
avoid it's just too much so we just have
to win the cultural battles daily wise
doing a fantastic job
i'll i'll tell you guys this you know i
joke about chicken city making a bunch
of money and being so successful but you
need to understand
we just we just made a minute long
little short which is totally family
friendly and it's like looney tune style
comedy
this is a family-friendly show
where we are going to get people you
know parents and their kids watching
this stuff
we're going to be pulling them towards
our sphere of influence
so
you bring them over you say hey look
there's no political messaging there's
no it's just a bunch of chickens it's
fun it's funny the kids watch it we make
little shorts that are fun for the for
adults because i thought it was
hilarious but the kids can watch it too
you build the culture then we have pop
culture crisis hosted by brett dasovich
and mary morgan where they comment on
the culture and talk about these issues
because we want to participate in this
we want to you you know it's it's like
looking at a group of people all talking
about something and being like i should
be able to stand here and yell at them
and they should agree with me it's like
no no go in there shake their hands talk
to them be like what do you think hey
come over here i want to show you
something that's what we're trying to do
no one gave a crap about me in high
school until i started acting and then
they all started laughing and then they
liked me do the same thing in reality
with business and then and then after
everybody liked him he started talking
about magnetic fields and they went i
didn't know that that's when you get
them you got once you got them then you
could tell them all about the magnetic
nature of the universe god's energy
flowing through you exactly
so
you can't approach someone as an other
you know if you see a guy in a suit you
can't act like a hippie if you see a
hippie you can't act like a guy in a
suit you have to meet people on their
terms so
if we if i think for the longest time
one of the problems conservatives have
had is that they you talk radio and
complain oh what these woke leftists are
doing we do it you know we complain
about it but you got to do a little bit
more than that that's why we basically
have one political show which is this
and then we've been focusing on making
cultural shows and cultural content so
that the people who already know these
things can watch something else they
have an alternative to disney or netflix
and then people who don't watch this
might not care to watch it but might
really enjoy watching chicken cartoons
with their family or something or eric
weinstein's theory of geometric unity
open invite eric if you want to come on
some friday
yes
all right let's uh let's let's grab some
more super chats
say uh
ratnapper says taylor on matt binder's
podcast confirmed that she knew an
address she had was in fact a private
home address it was the the picture libs
of tic toc snapped a friend or door
confirmed by taylor
well there you go
they knew what they were doing
weird they just lie about it and also if
they did like i said if they didn't
that's worse isn't it isn't this person
supposed to be a journalist
yeah how would you not know everyone
else figured it out after they published
the story same with saki like it's
either what's worse that you're really
stupid or that you're malicious i don't
know well
you're an activist the politics comes
first all the other things come second
which is
respect for privacy accuracy and
fairness if you're
that's not you know that's not
journalism that that story is about that
was activism it was an effective voice
against transgender extremism and the
abuse of government employees of school
children teachers
and they they wanted and it was and it
was having a political impact and they
needed to get it taken down and the way
to do it was suggest to a suggests
misconduct
and direct the accountability for that
fake misconduct at an individual and
everything else was secondary to that
right on we got lon who says this is for
sheamus towards him doing the biden
shower dog cartoon
come on man maybe yeah maybe we're gonna
have to do it dave if anyone by the way
like i said um on twitter just please
tweet the link at me if you have found
the audio of biden actually saying this
because i would love to have that
accompany the animation just use his
actual yeah i think i think your voice
would work work fine oh you're too kind
man yeah but it would be wrong he would
just animate it over his own that's what
he yeah what's what we did with our corn
pop video yeah really good thank you all
right uh
david c cook senior cronk senior says i
just find it humorous that now we can
pull audio out of context of ian saying
i'm just picturing joe biden in a towel
nothing bad
at least i can see the towel
yeah
troubling
all right
that's a good one there you go that's
funny
okay
oh man my nose my allergies get your
water angsta says so joe biden hurt his
ankle coming fresh out of the shower and
lifting his dog's tail no wonder major
was biting people he was being abused
maybe i think i think joe's embellishing
perhaps i don't know
all right let's see let's grab another
one let's just scroll down and see some
super jets
brent anderson says for the irish hobo
who's who who could he possibly be
talking about i just want to point out
that sheamus has ireland behind him but
he's from chicago that's true that's
true
yeah but look it's not my fault i don't
go around going oh top of the monitor i
mean irish lad why don't you refer to me
as one it's just people call me that it
wasn't my choice was my decision i know
i know oh he's a plastic paddy he wasn't
really born here i don't care i'm not
telling people to call me this is famous
he's got arnold come on everybody it's
an admission called patties
um because it's it's actually one guy
yeah it's people they won't they'll
never tell you that but patty has
monopolized mcdonald's yeah people don't
know also irish guy no but for real
though i mean i i i
every time i go to an irish pub it's
patties yep yeah wow there's burger
patties too but it's with the tea is
that the same you're you're you're
you're asking too many questions yeah
you can't ask that steve steve patron
saint of ireland that's why it's petty
aaron royer says we just canceled our
netflix account and use the money to
sign up at timcast.com keep up the great
work i'm not gonna tell you not to do
that yeah because i would prefer to uh
as jeremy boring said stop giving your
money to people who hate you give it to
me instead yes and that is brilliant
brilliant it's a great line um
i'll say it again you know
we've seen so much of like guys cancel
hulu cancel disney cancel netflix and
everyone does and then signs right back
up later when a new show comes out so
i'm like that's not the issue the issue
is yes cancel them but they need
somewhere to go so until we can say
leave netflix and go to the daily wire
you know i guess we can say that now but
the daily wear has like what three
movies yeah i think they're they have
four shows
as of like a few weeks ago or three
weeks ago i don't know to be honest i
really don't know they need more yes
they do once there's a big library then
you can be like there you go there's
your culture there's your entertainment
um i do think it's good if you want to
cancel your netflix account not support
them i don't have one i've never i'm
just saying i don't want to be
i want i want to make sure that you're
still involved in the culture so that
you can have influence in culture
so that we can all say
that new show that's coming out called
he's expecting is dumb and i don't want
to watch it
yes i know
arnold was in a movie called junior
where he was a pregnant man and that was
silly as well making a new show about it
especially now i'm just not interested
but back that that was also i mean that
wasn't i've never seen it but it was
intended to be satirical as far as i
understand i don't think they were
trying to say men can actually have
babies well this new show is basically
about with the new one i'm talking about
arnold there's a big difference between
milton berle and address and drag queen
story hour you know but the new show
he's expecting is not about trans men
it's a fictional scripted show where
some weird no it's a it's a live-action
show where something happens where all
of a sudden a man gets pregnant and
freaks out like how is this possible and
they're like we don't know it's not an
issue of someone being trans or anything
like that it's a it's a regular dude and
it's like it's very much like junior and
so i'm like it's happened before
i just think it's dumb especially in
today's context yeah i was going to say
in the present cultural context it
definitely seems like they're trying to
spread a different message and they do
in the trailer do say says and stuff
okay we need more action movies that
rely more on the actors than on the
freaking spectacle forget about the the
great graphics and crap we need good
powerful acting in action
let's see itsy bitsy spider says 420 was
the police code in california for a
marijuana violation this was in use in
the 90s the mo you know is that true
that sounds like it's not sounds true i
don't think it's true
yeah i don't know if that's true
i'm a fact checker on twitter now so one
of my fact checks is uh sounds true
yeah
joseph says 401ks are a ponzi scheme is
that true
i don't think that's true matter of
opinion they just keep your money until
that inflates and it becomes worth it
social security is that check it's worse
than that
all right let's grab some more
raymond g stanley jr says tim man we
were so close to a once again experience
in the history of tim cast irl the
classic quote of no you're wrong ian
you're wrong
that's good
all right speaking of being wrong i just
wanted to clarify that he's expecting is
based on a manga the netflix you said it
wasn't anime i said it was well my my
point was that it's based on some kind
of japanese show so it's not technically
like some kind of leftist propaganda as
such it's a weird story about a guy
getting i mean if you buy it like if
someone writes a story and you're like
that fits my agenda i'll take it yeah
what's the difference yeah
liberation matrix says tim has planning
begun on an apprenticeship internship
program for the first time workers to
further promote healthy culture building
for the youth great opportunities
through freedom stand with this
oh man
we are we are building as fast as we can
build and it's not super easy but i'd
love to have some kind of internship
thing
you guys want to start a city i don't
know if i'd call it internship i'd just
be like we'll hire some minimum wage
people to just like kind of hang out and
do stuff and help us with like odd jobs
well you know i would recommend that you
do internships because you can
credential
uh some good young folks for further
work in the industry so you uh and
interns are a great way to do that yeah
a lot of these personalities so you get
a chance to meet people and figure out
if they work with the chemistry of the
environment i mean you get the intern
comes in and gets does work and he has a
resume or she has a resume
line that says you know i work for one
of the top podcasters and and internet
personalities in the country i've had
news organization whatever they want to
say about it and they go on and do know
you know you never i can't tell you i've
been along in in this business long
enough to see interns be in positions of
influence and it's uh it's gratifying to
see
and it's important that if you're in the
business that we're in terms of trying
to educate and save the country to get
young people involved in the process so
we launched a couple of original shows
we uh we hired people and we've got
these shows that we started but one
thing that we want to do now is we've
begun scouting out
talent
in cultural politics and entertainment
so the idea is to find someone who seems
to be passionate working really really
hard
and is just
not necessarily cracking that barrier
and and taking off
but so we're looking for people who
already have a long history of of
content proven talent and then we want
to basically fund shows and get them
involved at tim cast like basically
like buy their show and and have tim
cass launch it the uh intern thing is a
debate and like an ethical debate i've
had it at mines particularly
corporations in the past and now that
like is it is it right to use because
it's you you're basically using labor
for free which is like that's
capital isn't just money capital is your
ability to create as well i have to stop
you you cannot legally have unpaid
interns anymore since the past 10 years
okay good but you pay them very little
you can you can minimum we have to be
paid hourly wages okay oh minimum wage
it depends on the program if it's a if
it's an internship affiliated with the
school there may be rules about what
you're able actually to do because
they're getting a benefit at the school
that they can so
about environments like this is you have
an opportunity to create your career
which is worth way more than money
right but we we so unpaid interns cannot
do anything that is considered a
critical function in the company good so
i think that's that's righteous so that
means if we had someone as an unpaid
intern and then said take the garbage
out can't do it cool they can sit there
hang out and watch
maybe get the coffee i guess
but if you have them just in this
essential function that's where you get
hit this happened 11 years ago i think
or or 12 no no maybe it was like maybe
it was ten years ago nine years ago
actually
i think it was from the time i was at
vice supreme court ruled and then all of
a sudden vice like just i i think this
is what happened i could be wrong but
i'm pretty sure they got rid of like all
of their interns and and all these
people were devastated because they were
like on that vice you know i'm in line
to get a job and then they're like
supreme court ruling everybody out can't
have you and then a handful of them got
started getting wages so they were like
i didn't get eliminated
yeah but you know can't have unpaid
people can't do it i wouldn't i wouldn't
do that anyway i would i would never
have an unpaid position unless i like
got some other form of capital that
doesn't seem right i suppose if people
uh
if we had an intern who literally just
hung out and did nothing
you know i wouldn't pay for that but i
wouldn't do that anyway like i'm not
going to have people come over here and
just sit around doing nothing
but uh we could we could we could stand
for uh a couple people who literally
just hang out and get paid minimum wage
to do odd odds and ends because i was
like even if like you could make them
famous put someone on a tv show and make
at the top even that's not ethical to
not pay someone because i think that's
hollywood figured that out already you
can't not pay people they want that job
doesn't mean you can't not pay that you
cannot pay them so they had to create a
union to protect these people well these
actions
consult your labor lawyer and get some
interns all right tarkina mayor says is
a youtube tim cast irl membership the
same as a timecast.com membership it is
not
timcast.com is a website where you sign
up and then you get you you get access
to the paywall on stuff we're going to
be also we're also looking for opinion
writers and analysis for paywall content
so if people want to read analysis and
opinion articles they have to pay for it
but we want we want the news to always
be free
i don't want to have like a breaking
news story like you know washington post
docs is someone's private address
and then you're like i need to read this
and it's locked that that nah we want
that to we want that to be free but the
challenge then is how do you pay for the
journalists to write it
it is a it is a conundrum these days
basically we're just like i hope you
guys like what we do enough to where you
will be like i'm gonna pay
because it's good they're doing this
work and cnn is bad and we don't like
them
so you know you do you can
uh we also have other strategies for
monetizing the website uh one of the
things i've never been a fan of is
automated ads
so we've been trying we've been doing
something for a while now you'll notice
for those that don't use adblockers the
ads on the website are for our own book
tales from the inverted world we're
trying to just make our own products so
you know infowars has their own health
products i wouldn't go that far
you know making like tim cast mega brain
or whatever no but we'll do stuff that
we're into like we wrote
you know shane cashman wrote a book
working for timcast.com and we advertise
we want to sell it another book is
coming out we want to sell it we we
could theoretically make our own uh 3d
printed figurines and sell them and i'm
still laughing about tim cast's mega
brain please make it tim cast a mega
brain yeah let's do it that'll be the
one we do make
tim cast mega brain get it now
and uh you know
you take the pills then you have to put
your beanie on leave it on overnight for
it to work hot that's right it
stimulates your neurons
make one called hot head
i don't i don't care for any of those
things to be honest like you know so we
do reads for biotrust and it's simple i
started doing keto a while ago
i like it the keto stuff i skate all the
time and it's really intense and i like
the collagen it's really simple i'm like
hey shout out biotrust these are things
i can actually understand and use but
what it's like this blend of tree barks
and flowers will like make your eyes you
know bulge i'm just like yeah i want to
know
what it does chemically in your body
before i start selling it personally
yeah you know we we've talked about
doing um
some stuff like like a protein mct mix
or something like that
uh but we want to have our own products
so
right now we have books for for what we
do on the website i'm not interested in
weird ads from weird companies so we
want to move away from all of that and
we've mostly done that
and we want to start making our own
stuff like the daily wire gave us the
truth bomb i'm like that's a great
product it's literally just a paper
weight and it's a truth bomb it's great
we need stuff like that like you know
crystals or whatever
okay we'll just sell our own stuff you
got me thinking all right everybody if
you have not already beanie brain that's
what luke said beanie break i was just
thinking if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show wherever you can
if you want to help us grow and go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have that segment coming up at about 11
or so p.m you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
tom do you want to shout anything out
hey uh great book out we got
judicialwatch.org obviously people
should donate to our work
also the
republic under assault is uh
already out in hardcover and the
paperbacks coming out next month so look
for that
all right freedom too by the way it was
great having you back again good
discussions uh freedom tunes is my
youtube channel if you all want to check
that out we uploaded a video yesterday
that i think was pretty funny audience
did too it was uh our number one video
of the past couple months and we're
releasing one tomorrow that i also think
is gonna be an absolute banger you guys
are really gonna love it go check it out
i love you you can follow me ian
crossland.net i'm still on fire from my
interview with michael malus on your
welcome episode 203 go check it out on
youtube subscribe and let me know in the
comments what you think leave a comment
in this episode too and let us know what
you thought about this show i want to
hear from you bye for sure thanks so
much for tuning in tonight guys thank
you tom for coming out ian's episode
sounds fantastic i'm gonna have to watch
that after the show tonight you guys may
follow me on twitter at mines.com at
sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlist.me
and as a special announcement if you are
someone listening and you have
experience running a sandwich shop
send an email to spin the ufo gmail.com
oh yeah because we are uh planning on
opening a sandwich shop and then a venue
but i'm not kidding about that sandwich
shop maybe maybe we'll have coffee
finish bread
fresh bread different kinds of bread
remember i told you about the man
sandwich that's what i was saying that
you walk in and there's no there's no
frills there's no bs you're like i'm a
man what kind of meat you want roast
beef turkey or you know ham i want
turkey done and they just do your
sandwiches there like we don't waste
time here they bang on the table the
whole time
and then uh you know the chips it's like
potato chip that's it that's all you get
you get you get potato chip
there's one flavor i got ideas i'll tell
you it's totally opposite of what you're
talking about so it's definitely gonna
work i just want like a simple
i want to open my own sandwich place
because i love
simple healthy food
i don't care for like the give me the
triple cheese double bacon chicken ranch
i was like dude give me roast beef
tomato lettuce cheese like i love jimmy
john's so we want to do something like
that but we're also going to be opening
a venue
and then um but we'll talk about it
because maybe we'll do coffee instead
because i also love coffee my family did
own a coffee house at one point coffee
yeah for a couple years before we went
out of business and so maybe that's what
we should do we should bring that back
and then we will exclusively sell
krigler coffee ladies and gentlemen one
of the best coffees in the world all
right everybody we'll see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you